我们再来看一个很多同学经常问的对吧？赢时排名前几的片子，肖申克的救赎。
我们简单看几场他的结尾的戏。
My wife used to say I'm a hard man to know.
嗯，不。
Ped about it all the time.
She是beautiful。
看了这。
等拿的时候再走。
Q的人。
pull the trigger.
And drove away.
That's why she died because of me.
我呀。
Don't make you murderer.
还是本。
Youe feel bad about it if you want to, but you didn't pull the trigger.
What else did.
And I wound up in here.
多少感以。
月啊。
都s around。
来南 somebodybody。
来 turn呢走。
还 in the path of the窗那。
Didn't expect the storm would last as long as it is.
I think you'll ever get out of here.
没。
对呀。
One day when I got a long white beard and two or three marbles rolling around upstairs, they like me.
这我爱 girl。
就 afternoon。
贼最我真的样。
Mexico。
place on the Pacific Ocean.
You know the Mexican say about the Pacific.
It has no memory.
Where I want to live the rest of my life.
W place no memory.
From up a little hotel.
Right on the beach.
I some worthless old boatin.
Makes it up now.
该 sir。
全人fish。
谁完内。
Like that, I could use man that knows how to get things.
看你下子年的。
没有。
anything most of my life.
I'm an institutional man now.
It's like Brooks flies.
W, you underestimate yourself.
I don't think so.
In here, I'm the guy who can get things for you sure.
Outside all you need is the yellow pages, hell I wouldn't even know where to begin.
Pacific Ocean.
是。
scare me to death something that big let me.
I didn't shoot my wife and I didn't shoot her lover.
Whatever mistakes I made, I paid for them and then so.
I't tell that book.
I don't think that's too much to ask.
I don't think you ought got to be doing this to yourself, an they, this is a shitty pipe dreams.
I mean, Mexico was way to show down there and you're in here and that's the way it is.
Yeah, right, that's see what it is.
It's down there, I'm in here.
it comes down in a simple drawer, really.
嗯。
这几个人。
自的爱了。
爱你。
嗯。
If you ever get out of here, do me a favor.
确 anything。
The big hay field up near Buxton, you know where Buxton is?
There's a lot of hayfield up there one in particular, it's got a long rock wall, a big oak tree at the north end, it's like something out of a Robert frost hole.
Where I asked my wife to marry me.
I went there for a picnic.
love under that oak.
she said, yes.
re.
If you ever get out, find that spot.
Based to that wall, you'll find a rock that has no earthly business in a main Hafield.
some black volcanic glass.
There's something buried under it I want you to have.
我来奶。
What's better?
。
快了。
不是。
And to crawl to freedom through 500 yards of shit smelling foulness I can't even imagine, or maybe I just don't want to.
啊。
500 yards.
That's the length of five football fields, just shy of half a mile.
稍毒啊，快去卷他。
不敢 friend of his。
定。
2 three7.
This is conspiracy.
That's what this is.
Be damn conspiracy and everyone on it her.
1966, And Du Fin escaped from Shao Shank prison.
All they found of him was a muddy set of prison clothes, a bar of soap, and an old rock on her da worn down to the nub.
Remember thinking it would take a man 600 years to tunnel through the wall with it.
欧land less than团。
来。
肖申克的救赎先给大家说一下肖申克的救赎的AB故事。因为很多同学一直问。
肖申克的救赎，他的庇故史藏的并不深，同学们竟然找不到。
他就藏在。
他的标题里。
肖申克的救赎啊，懂啊，救赎呀。
他的庇护史其实就是救赎。
救赎肖申克是这个监狱的名字嘛？
他们在这个监狱里面的救赎。
A故事当然是。
追求。
自由我们说A故事是外在的嘛？他追求什么自由？
肉体的自由。
简单说就是你们说的越狱。
越狱A股市上。
他办的事儿就是越狱。
我们。
换一句话说叫追求外在的自由，肉体的自由。
我跟你们说过，A故事是什么来着？并驾齐驱，一内一外一虚一时。
明白吗？B故事是追求什么？你现在已经知道了，追求心灵的自由嘛，对吧？我要追求心灵的自由，那你的心灵是什么困住了你的心灵呢？是什么给你的心灵带来了牢笼呢？显然不是肖申克的高墙呀，是什么呢？
是罪恶。
是原罪。
所以庇故室是救赎。
救赎。
你看那个安迪说了吗？
按理说我没有杀我老。
或者是说我没有亲手杀我老婆。
但我也对他的死有责任，我的冷漠对吧？我对家庭的冷漠。
我有责任。
然后他在最后这个这个高潮戏这里，他在越狱之前，最后跟。
那个那个red就摩根夫里曼那个角色，他最后跟red说的话是什么？说不管我犯过什么错，我的罪已经输光了。我在这里待了这么多年，是是呃十9还是20年的，对吧？我已经付了我我的。
代价了。
其实他想说的就是我的赎罪已经完成了，我的B故事完成了，我现在要去办A了，对吧？这个人很讲究啊。
因为大部分人是先办A再办B呀。
就A办不成才想起来有个B。
对吧不管是什么摇滚校园啊，我没你们看过摇滚校园，对吧？摇滚校园的A股AB故事是什么？什么来着？
A故事是是是是是是去组乐队赢奖金。
对吧利用那些贵族小孩儿。
呃，组乐队拿奖金。B故事是你如果想要组乐队拿奖金，你如果想要那个那个得到这些，你得成为一个好歌手，你得自己成长。
对吧。
但是那种戏呢，那个人就是先走AA碰的一鼻子灰，最后发现啊B故事才是人生的真谛。
但是咱们这个片子这个片子为什么评分这么高？
对吧这个片子评分高。
他当然是有它的道理，他当然是有它非常精妙的结构，但是它的结构依然符合。
商业片的原理。
就是他的这个AB故事仍然是以外以内。但是这个安迪很潇洒，呃，他先把笔办完了，人家先办高尚了，我已经数足已经数好了，现在哎。
我要走了，我颠了，他明显最后那场戏就是在给给跟rad暗示告别嘛，对吧？
啊，另外说一句啊，肖申克的救赎。
他的救赎不仅仅是。
指安迪瑞德也就赎了嘛。
对吧乐队也就赎了。
也付出了他的代价，变成了一个好人。然后。
他最后去海边去找安迪了嘛。
还有那个狱长。
大人的预警。
全都付出了自己的代价。
全都。
救赎了那个那个狱长自杀了吗？那不也是救赎吗？
所以肖申克的救赎。
这场高潮戏为何如此精彩？你自己看这7个它是不是都符合？
连最难搞的AB合题这一条，它都符合的很完美，对吧？他做出的抉择，它的烈度就再次意外是吧？全都有。我们说文戏里面我们还有一个经常举例的电影。
阳光小美女。
阳光小美女可以说是公路片的这是这个巅峰之作。
他的结局是什么？
Now please put your hands together once again and help me welcome to the stage, our 12 beautiful contestants.
Baby。
二姐on美。
。
let's have a big round applause for our lovely contestants.
One of these girls will be crowned Little Miss Sunshine.
Hy honey, are you okay there?
按出来。
嗯。
I got a kid in the show.
我是他。
一样。
爸爸。
是merica。
And now the moment we have all been waiting for, the talent competition.
G my regards to Broway, remember me to Her.
。
Fingulation。
哦，那个爷。
嘿。
It's gone on.哦, I just take you your shop.
哪里歌子。
I就 know我的。
别。
这。
你两个不可以，刚晚过去，他们两个商量。
Hey, how are you feeling Where'ss up, I don't want doing my god I don't want these people judging all fuck them it is too late. No, it's not too late. You're the mom and you're supposed to protect her. Everyone is going to laugh at her.
Please don't her do this Ill over two minutes.
She's not a beauty queen.
就什么。
No you listen to me Olive is who she is she has worked so hard, she's poured everything into this, we can't just take it away from her, we can't.
I know you want to protect her I know honey but.
olive be olive.
Oli Hoover, are you the family?
嘿。
O, it's time okay.
呀。
不 gotta go你嗯。
You don't want to do this, that's okay.
If you want to sit this one out, it's totally fine by us, we're proud of you anyway.
要那个。
Its time.
喂，我这个。
可你。
Copy that 25 is performance ready and we're walking.
Asast as we can.
。
Your fairytale magic Mris.
Welcome that a Stardust fantasy. Thank you for that. You have been such a a patient audience. We have one more contestant, and then we'll be crowning our women. Please give a warm welcome to M.
Allhoover。
嗯。
I'd like to dedicate this to my grandpa who showed me these mo Oh, that is so sweet.
here where's your grandpa right in the trunk of our car?
O well, take it away, olive.
off the streets out。
来 the boys in the band。
So that I'm a multi favorite when I make my move to her room, it's the right time.
I really loving.
是否说不会说不在，心说不会。
right with me。
是什么鬼什么飞。
。
哪嘞。
昂的东方。
。
耶。
阳光小美女几句话讲这个故事就是一个小胖妞，乡下小胖妞竟然异想天开，想去参加阳光小美女的这个一个选美活动。
然后呢，他家一家人全是。
loser。
对吧老爸是一个卖不出书的。
呃，这个这个讲师讲成功学的老妈呢家庭妇女还烟瘾，对吧？然后呢，舅舅自杀未遂，哥哥呢呃色盲想考飞行员，而且还从来不说话。爷爷呢吸毒，然后去的路上还死了，吸还欧弟死了，吸毒过量死了。
就是这么一家人，然后决定陪这个小女孩去实现他的梦想参加选美。其实呢寓意非常明确，就是一家人都要实现自己的梦想嘛。
最后。
这场高潮戏结局戏是什么呢？这个小女孩等终于在一家人的努力下，终于登上了这个选美比赛的舞台。
终于登上了这个选美比赛的舞台，目的达到了，对吧？但是呢这些全都有满足的期待。
上台了，但是以观众没有想到的方式，别人都跳健美操、跳拉丁、跳芭蕾，他跳了一段脱衣舞。
他跳了一段脱衣舞，因为他的舞蹈是吸毒的爷爷教的对吧？兑现伏笔了。他前面他他爷爷一直训练他跳舞，但是从来没有给跳舞的镜头。而且他爷爷吸毒嫖娼什么的，就是不是什么一个正经老头，对吧？
然后。
意外反转都非常的足。就是。
跳这个舞。
肯定是得不了奖啊，是不可能获得名次的，但是获得了很多现场观众的支持。
觉得这个这是孩子的天性呀。
然后他的一家人。
我们说这个戏的主角是谁？就是这一家人叫美国底层民众。
从他们开着车，从他们穿的衣服，从他们的居住环境，从他们吃的东西。
一直在铺垫，这是一个美国底层家庭同村们遇到的问题。
然后他们这这个主角群。
面对的问题。
面对梦想。
敢不敢追求梦想，最后做出了抉择。
做出了牺牲，最先站起来支持。
我们的小美女的是谁？
是他自杀的舅舅。
最先站起来了，对吧？手上还缠着纱布，因为割腕自杀嘛。
他最先站起来，随后所有的全家庭成员全部站起来，支持梦想，其实是在支持自己的梦想呀。
对吧只是自己的梦想。
这就是。
主角的抉择AB故事更不用说了。A故事显然是去参加这个选美嘛。
参加这个选美。
我们说AB物事永远是内外的关系啊。参加选美，我们如果用一句。
外化的词，这是什么？
追求别人的认可。
对吧选美得奖，我们他那个气氛烘托的很足的呀，评委是什么样的对吧？那个尖酸刻薄那个那个那个那个品头论足的那种感觉，对吧？
追求别人的认可。那闭护是呢？
这是有自己的认可。
对吧你要想别人认可你，你得自己认可你啊。
所以他就AB合体了。你可以说是B战胜了A，就我不需要别人的认可了，我只需要自己的认可。
你也可以说AB合一了。
我自己认可我自己了，别人才认可我。因为有一些观众为他们呐喊，为他们欢呼呀。
阳光小美女。
AB合体，对吧？
当然这些人家也都做到了，很容易理解。
这就是你看文戏的结局，各种各样的玩法，但是呢基本上都是从这7个方面下手。
再找两个武武戏打戏。很多同学不是说打戏，那打戏最后就没啥写了是吧，就让我的主角跟反派干呗，对吧？大战一百回合，让无指去搞吧，那也不行。我们想几个打戏的啊。
打戏结局的。
打戏用打戏做高潮的电影，也是咱们课上讲过的例子。第一个。
加勒比海盗。
加勒比海盗大家先看一下啊，这场打戏。
啊。
You're off the edge of the map made here there'll be monsters.
来就的鞋。
为你天。
That's interesting.
干啊。
买。
。
不妈。
2。
嘿。
ortals locked in an epic battle tru.
。
你这是怕是没丢人呢。
让你派人。
呀。
谢。
He is the of you like pain.
I wearing a close set.
drag on了。
看他慢慢的。
。
我。
回来。
10 years you carry that pistol. now you waste too short.
He didn't waste it.
fe。
加勒比海盗这场打戏，我们说是在藏宝的山洞里，藏宝洞里这场打戏。
打戏无一，节奏问题你就不用担心了，肯定刚刚干起来了，对吧？
然后。
这些你们看一下他有没有都符合。
我们说满足观众的期待呀，满足了观众的期待，正义战胜肯定战胜邪恶了呀，我方胜利是吧？但是呢是用你没有想到的方式。
肯定是有意外，有反转呀，有意外有反转呀。但是也对这些意外反转并不出格，兑现了之前的伏笔和悬念呀。我们说最后这场戏咋解决的？我们从这儿来看啊，主角的抉择加勒比海盗我讲过好几遍。
加勒比海盗我讲过好几遍，主角是特纳，是奥兰多布鲁姆。
他的抉择就是。
他用那个金币割破自己的手，沾上自己的血，扔回里面，把所有的丧尸。
那些不是不死之身吗？他把金币还回去之后，那些人的不死之身破除了才导致。
一枪把那个反译给干死了，对吧？他最后做出了抉择。
做出了抉择。
啥学择直面自己的身份嘛？你他是个海盗嘛，他就是特纳之子嘛？海盗嘛。
意外和反转都有，而且很足。那场戏最大的意外其实是啥？你知道吧？最大的意外其实是杰克船长也是丧失。
杰克船长在那跟那个反医咣咣打一刀被那个扎中了，对吧？眼看我们的最喜欢的这个这个这个捷克船长要死了，没死，他是不死之身，他也是丧尸。
反转和意外做的很足，你别看这是一场打戏，他所有的东西都有。
都有漂漂亮亮的。
别看就是一场打戏，人家也啥都有。
AB合体也是非常明确。我们说。
他的AB股市是啥？加勒比海盗AB股市是啥？
外在内在外在是什么？
找爱人，他不是去找那个吗？
找找那个伊丽莎白吗。
对吧一这沙白上海盗那个绑架了，他得去找他嘛。
外在是找爱人，内在呢？
找自己。
就是外在看起来是出海去找爱情，去找自己的爱人，找自己的爱情去。其实内在的问题你是去找自己。
你不是个小铁匠。
你不是个一般人。
你你再否认，再不愿面对也没用。
你上了船出了海，一路上发现我他妈就是个天生的海盗啊，是吧？找的是你自己，而且伊丽莎白在终终点就找着了。
最后根本不是找伊丽莎白，伊丽莎白在终点你就找着了。
在西的终点位置就找着了，最后B是找自己，他在这里AB合体，他面对自己海盗的身份，他用自己的海盗之雪特那之血。
弄到那个金币上扔回去，破除对手的不死之身。
AB合体好，这个加勒比海盗对吧？大戏照样符合我们说的这些明白了吧？同学们就讲这几个例子啊。
所以说咱希望通过这节课解决咱们这个。
高潮无力的问题，高潮戏顶不上去的问题。同学们。
多练习多琢磨吧。还是我说那句话啊，咱们从上节课开始，其其实就这些课的内容啊都已经不那么。
不那么对小白友好了，因为你要写你才知道我们在说什么。你才知道我们说的为什么说到了高潮那里，你总是一笔带过。
你才知道我们我们为什么这么说。
好吧，所以大家还是要多写多练。
然后这节课差不多就到这儿了。
给大家布置一下作业啊，布置一下作业，就是练习吧。
嗯，很多同学不知道写什么。
不知道从哪下笔的。
我今天给大家布置一个作业。
写你的一个家人。
我们不要写自己，也不要写一个镜花水月的人物，写你的一个家人。
不管是谁，你爸妈也行，你舅姥爷也行，你小弟也可以写你的一个家人。
因你耳朵里面听到的眼睛里面看到的关于他的故事。
写出来。
当然可以创造创作。
然后注意一下，用。
第三视角写，不要用你的视角写我的舅舅呃，不要这么写，对吧？
你舅舅比如说叫李宪，那你就写李宪的故事。
对吧一个男子叫李健，你这么去写第三视角好吧，大家练习一下，从其自己的家人下手。
嗯，挖掘素材。
艺术加工。
写一个故事好不好？这就是这节课的作业，咱们下课吧。
嗯。